Okay.
Um, let's see what we've got here. First
of
all, that's a nice
soda. That's a nice
soda. Let's just take a moment to uh to
appreciate that. is nice nice soda
Next. Yeah. So, uh this feature is
supposed to be off policy
correction, but it's not seeming very
off policy corrected to
me. But maybe we're doing something.
I guess we were going to just do
prioritized experience replay,
bit. Yeah. Yeah, that's what I was going
to do.
weird. I just really want to know their
sampling, you
know, ratio.
Where is the final
algorithm extensions?
[Music]
What's
this? I'll get to that later. Uh, I
really want to get this implemented as
well today.
do
P1 equals 1.
weight. I have no idea what this formula
is.
Did people use the rank base one or
what?
variables? Yeah. Okay. I've been uh I've
done like close to 10 hours of algorithm
dev today. So, we're going to just go to
this for easy motive
explain right out. The
formula
for Okay. N is the size the replay
buffer. Okay.
Duh. And this is P of
I. The heck is
accumulate weight
change. This is DQN, right?
So there are just using the
uh TD error.
So they actually put a schedule on
prioritize replay.
is this is what I was doing before.
Really
your sampling segments
non-uniformly. Use important sample
waiting to correct
bias in the policy
gradient. Oh, that's probably actually
important, isn't
it? Hang on. Isn't the whole point of
this to bias the policy gradient? I'm
confused.
is I'm being a little stupid at this
hour. This is uh this is actually very
simple. Fully compensates for
non-uniform probabilities if b equals 1.
Okay, I mean we can kind of just
implement this,
right? And then um alpha equals
0, beta equals
zero uh will just recover the original
sampling. So that's actually totally
fine. 727. Let's implement that in a
couple quick experiments and that will
be awesome progress for today.
Oh, you can just you can call this with
problems, right?
right? I don't know where it came up
with
this. This was definitely not the uh
So apparently all we have to do is
multiply by match
now. Sum to
one. Pretty
But I just want to get the initial
implementation
in. Hello YouTube
folks.
Welcome. All right. It runs. It does in
fact
run.
So this should now be
prioritized not across uh
epochs. This was the thing that was
missing
using importance weights.
It stalled out a bit, but I think it's
still pretty dang
good. So, we get
this. That's not bad.
This is with the new
uh vrace. We should also do this
equals file.
Okay. So now this is without V
trace. We didn't break
anything. We
didn't. Good.
So, let me uh just disable a whole bunch
of
these these stupid
playing. Yeah, this seems like uh
perfectly
fine.
Great. So,
um Now the question is going to be B
trace versus J E
sampling. We have this as our baseline.
This is our other
baseline. So we actually what we can do
is we can just
Oops. Okay. So here is our V
trace. Here is our J.
We're going to try a few more
things since we're in a trying stuff
mode.
Okay, so this is now BRA with all policy
data only a little
I mean, it does still learn, but it
learns slower.
This is also a bad environment for this,
right? Yeah, this is a bad environment
for
this. We should do
[Music]
thing. One
map size 31
fun. So I think in this case I probably
know how to fix this, right?
56. That should be fine, shouldn't
it? Why is this thing not working?
Maybe I didn't test this. Maybe I only
tested it this way.
So, I'm probably just leave it like this
and see what the solve rate is, right?
With the
betray. Yeah, this will be a good few
experiments.
Okay, so the PO baseline on this is
pretty nice and smooth.
We will also get to try this on
um on Nurmo 3,
right? We can just throw on
prioritized prioritized
replay now that we have
Okay, stalls out low 70s.
Next will be B
trades. Max uses goes from 27 to
1918 and mean
uses at So, there's definitely
prioritization
happening. There's definitely some
happening.
Uhoh. Does V trace just suck?
Let's see what the
uh I had some original results in
here. Find
it. So, this did get over like 085 or
something in 100
I'm watching your stream on YouTube.
Hello. You're allowed to ask stuff if
you're stuck. You know, that's half the
reason I stream.
So, I don't know what I did to this
environment, but
um so far the prioritized replay seems
fine.
It doesn't seem like I screwed anything
up
there. Yeah. If anything, this
multinnomial is less
consistent. So, it'll be worth throwing
this at
um neural MMO 3 just to see prior
Reapply priority play seems to have the
cleaner curve.
um
Okay. So, uh I think the prioritize
replay
is, you know, the prioritize replay is a
good addition.
Now then the question is just like what
the heck happened to
um Vrace, right? What happened with
Vrace? Cuz that's really weird for V
trace to do
that because it worked fine for
breakout. Shouldn't just fail.
um why is betray not work on
this? Hello. I was basically stuck
setting up on a run
machine. When I make ocean breakout, it
works fine. I print out the infos. I see
positive rewards and so
on. Okay. So, What's the setup issue
then? Some reason observation stays the
same like after every step I'm getting
the same.
Um, so the only thing that I can think
of that people get stuck on
[Music]
sometimes, what OS do those things
run? So, let me find this for
you. The way that our native MS
work, so all our native MS define this
buffer, observations, rewards,
whatever, and then they write stuff into
that buffer.
So if this is somehow go getting
overwritten or
whatever, something weird can happen
there. Try running with ve serial. See
if that changes anything. And if not,
like link me the
uh code you're
running because I've seen people do this
before. Oh, actually, I've literally had
people write
uh I've had people write this test
before and do it wrong. I've literally
had people write this like test. Link me
the test script you're running. It could
be if you're running a test script. I've
literally had people send me a test
script where uh they have this exact
issue and it's just the way they write
the
script.
VR, what's going on with you?
Why do you work on proper breakout but
then not on uh not on this m at
all link in the Discord YouTube will
yell at Okay.
Let's do this
[Music]
pryo
fish. Is this German or what is Google
fish? It's like something for proper
fish, I'm sure.
Hello. All right. So, it is genuinely
the case then
that irrespective of sampling it just
doesn't work
on this. Does it work on calm?
I mean it works doesn't work as well.
It's not optimized for this though.
not working at all on
um red is
Oh, that's got E3B
on. But I think I removed that already.
channel wherever you can put it in the
jam. It's fine.
Yep. So, here's the thing. Yeah, man. I
need to add like some docs on this. I
thought I actually did add docs on this.
So, it's just the way that you're
testing this. Um, just like just copy
this. I think you can like docopy or
whatever the
array. So the obs update in place. It's
the same tensor. That's the
problem. You see? So this is giving you
a handle to a
tensor, but then when you step the end,
it writes the new data to that same
tensor.
Like think about it because otherwise
you end up making a new tensor every
single time you step the end, right? And
like nobody ever thinks about that. But
when you end up when you're doing
reinforcement learning at millions of
steps per second, you have to think
about stuff like that. So your thing is
completely correct. You've got no issues
with it. It's just um yeah puffer native
ms will update the temper in place. The
same will be true of the rewards dons
trunk like they all get updated in
place.
all written to shared buffer. Yeah, cuz
so the way the multipprocessing works,
right?
Um there's like this one big shared
buffer and then it gives you it just
gives you slices of that buffer.
Sometimes it can copy. It depends. But
generally like the way to look at it is
you should not assume that you're going
to be handed a unique
buffer. But the thing is like as soon as
you do it like as soon as you put it
into a torch tensor and like move it to
the GPU, it's going to get copied
anyway. So you're never going to have a
problem with that in practice.
V trace just straight up doesn't work
here. That's
weird. It's very
weird. Tra just straight up doesn't work
on the grids.
weird. So there's more work to do on V
trace. I got the initial implementation
at
least. I guess I can rerun neural MMO
now with prioritized replay as well,
right?
it. It can't be this.
[Music]
Solid, solid
progress. I need that box back
though
because we need to run new job.
All right, this thing can report back in
when it's uh played another thousand
years of neural
MMO. That's what 50 billion steps is.
It's about a thousand years worth of
games
played right there. That is
soda. But uh you know, we can't have
soda with a learning curve that looks
like this. I'm hoping that the
prioritize replay cleans this up a
little bit. We will see. Maybe it does,
maybe it
doesn't. Looks like another good end. I
can chuck this
Do you like Pink
Floyd? I cannot name you a single Pink
Floyd
song. I listen to very little music in
general.
I kind of just like do reinforcement
learning research, keep in shape,
occasionally play a game or two. It's
about it.
This is kind of the all
consuming pursuit of RL
has. I don't know. Like some number of
months
ago, I was on a date with like a really
cute girl and she started talking about
like music and stuff and I just went,
"Oh yeah, I have zero topics of
conversation cuz I do RL all day long. I
should probably just go finish all the
RL." I can just go solve that field so I
can do other
stuff. Let's just go solve the field so
I can move on to other things,
right? Cuz nothing's going on in the
meantime. Freaking all
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. I forgot about that.
People like listen to music and stuff,
right? Oh
yeah. I got a I got a coil wine on this
desktop next to me. Does that
count? No. No. No. No. It plays
different notes depending on what jobs
you run on the GPU. You know, if you
load it really heavy, you get one coil
wind pattern. And if you load it
slightly less, you get another one.
The hell is wrong with this thing? Why
is this thing
hanging? Is this V
trace or is this just hanging?
Okay, I think this is just like dev
branch shenanigans.
Can we get like something to work?
Maybe. How about puffer
snake? Small time funs to try to do RL
at a little more scale. And here I am
attempting to get puffer lip going, but
thanks. Yeah. Hey, I
mean, here to help.
I pretty much just build this thing
24/7.
So, this is going to be this kind of
already is the place to go for a wide
range of RL
applications. Like a ton of different RL
problems you can think of. Popper is
kind of the best thing already and uh it
will only continue to become the best
thing for everything as we keep doing
stuff except LL. I don't really care to
bother with our
LMLs, at least not at the moment. But
other than
that, probably the best place is
Why? Okay. Definitely B trace is not
uh V tracing.
If someone else were to get the LM part
into
Popper, would you be down on what
criteria to have for it? I mean, is
there like actually a useful thing that
we can do or is this just going to be
like the latest bandwagon thing, right?
So like Puffer's ultra ultra high
performance aura, right? We do training
at this is literally a million and a
half steps per second and that's slow.
It should be two million steps per
second. That's a regression.
Um, so like when in llm land you're
doing RL like two steps per
second, like you can write the dumbest
code imaginable and you're probably not
going to bottleneck anything when the
LLM is the slow part, right?
So, like, yeah, I do actually hope that
some of the techniques and stuff that we
come up with with Puffer are going to be
useful for LLM land, but is there like
anything we can really do with it in the
meantime? I don't
know. If it prints enough free money for
me to fund a cool private industry lab
for the next several years, then yeah,
that that'd be awesome, too.
But I'm kind of chilling just like
working on solving the rest of RL right
now because nobody else is going to do
it. And I can't I cannot bear to see RL
be thrown to the wayside
when it has so so much
potential. I think we're going to just
have consistent, stable, and working
this
What the hell is
this? What are you doing?
Beats. Okay. I thought that you didn't
have to normally advantage the beach
race,
right? This breaks it, doesn't it? I
think that this like just instantly
breaks
it. If I do this, it instantly breaks,
doesn't
grabs. Yeah. So, the kales are blowing
up there.
See, amusingly the spores are a little
bit higher than before, but they're not
going to keep going up. It's not going
to be stable like that.
something? Do I literally just have to
do
this? All are really
unwieldy. Huge
bandwagon doing chain of thought.
Yeah, but like bandwagons are boring,
right? Like everybody doing a thing
doesn't make me want to do it. It makes
me want to go do something else.
the super
wacko.
Um, where's
our have a run here, shouldn't
we? Yeah, we got to run there,
huh? Hang on. This is this
something? It's got a little bit of
variation there
already. That's
promising. True. If I'm being honest,
I'd rather get better at dev and
contribute to buffer. It's a fun
time. I mean, this is the place to be if
you're looking to like actually make a
difference in the science and like do so
without needing to like
I don't know. It's like one of the
places where like a lot of people with a
lot of different skills can contribute
meaningfully, right? If you're just good
at writing code, you can make really
useful research gems really, really
fast. Um, you know, if you've got the
science background, we have all sorts of
science we're doing, right? If you've
got like perf engineering, make our [ __ ]
faster. There's like so much stuff we
can do and all the code is like
relatively easy to work with.
It moves really fast as
well. We have We have some hardware
contributors, too, and we're going to
get more of
it. That just get a
spike.
Oh, well, let's not get our hopes up,
but that could be really darn good. Did
that a 500 mil? comes off the ground at
mil. That's pretty
cool. Prioritized replay for
the I like just testing stuff on neural
MMO cuz like it's the hard end and it's
fast.
No, my favorite side my favorite part
with all this stuff like occasionally I
like doing some of the research stuff. I
guess I get bored so I jump around
between different things but I think
like on the whole uh I prefer the
engineering work. I really like low
level
dev pure math background recently
getting into ML and especially
RL I'll look around learn C and so on
hey I mean you know the one thing I
don't have is a half decent math
background I don't know I took
like I took whatever joke math you take
when uh you really just want to do
engineering I don't know I guess I took
Um, I took maybe like one actual math
department class, a few of like the CS
proof based mathematics courses and like
you know your PTE and whatever else, but
that's it. Few linear algebra courses
it. So, I like I'll like sit it like
you'll see me working through papers on
stream and like I'll get through stuff,
but it'll take me a long
time. Um, like one of the things I was
trying to figure out
today, like I was looking at rainbow,
right? And I was looking at like this
multi-step return.
I'm pretty sure this totally breaks
the off policy
assumption because
like you have an action condition value
function. That's your Q function. But
that only gives you the outcome of the
next step for every action. So if you
step several ahead, I don't think you
can still learn on those segments off
policy
correctly. I don't know. But then
somebody linked me this other paper.
Where is it?
Meme
paper. Yeah, this
thing. And apparently this thing uses
160 step trajectory
segments. So basically I've been looking
through some random papers trying to
figure out a decent way to do like off
policy correction so that we can do PO
with an experience buffer.
And so far I haven't gotten anything to
work. You're you're getting here when
I'm about to get off bed. But uh
welcome. We did implement Bra. It works
on breakout mostly
pawn. Doesn't seem doing well very well
on anything else though.
though. I don't freaking know. Maybe
it's
bugged. I think I pushed the code. You
could look at it. It's a bunch of
math. I mean, really, the only code for
it
is. So it's in
here. So it's just this piece of C code
right
here. And everything else is kind of
just bindings for this. Bindings for the
C extension, bindings for the CUDA
is. Took a hell of a long time to get
this to like even work at
all. I did something kind of cool as
well. So
um you can run this in C on you can run
this exact code. This function will run
on the CPU or on the GPU because it's
simultaneously valid C and valid CUDA.
Yeah, I actually I really like that I I
did this. So
like if you go to
pufferlib.cpp, vrace just runs a for
loop over that function, right? But if
you go to pufferlib.cu,
CU then the vtrace kernel just gets the
CUDA like block variables the you know
the CUDA built into the block variables
and then it runs it there in
parallel. Why does endstep return break
off
policy? It seems like it would, doesn't
it? Like
um so the idea is that with the
bootstrap onestep turn, right? The Q
function gives you the value of
essentially you can pick any action and
then get the value associated with
taking that action and then following
the optimal policy thereafter. Right?
But uh with the
endstep you can't get the outcome of
taking the optimal policy thereafter
because you have like several rewards
several intermediate rewards from the
old policy
right I don't know maybe it is valid for
off policy it didn't seem like it was
and the thing that suggests to me that
it isn't is that um you would think that
doing a longer bootstrap would be
better, right? So, if this were valid,
doing a longer bootstrap should be
strictly better. Well, they literally
bootstrap three-step intervals and it's
they say it starts doing worse if they
try to use like even fivestep intervals,
right? And on policy learning, we're
using like 32, 64, 128, right? The
longer the
Also, this paper is absolutely a meme
because 200x faster actually means like
20x slower but 200x fewer samples or
whatever. Do they explain that? Of
course not.
goes. I don't know. Read the paper. Just
rainbow.
My brain's kind of [ __ ] I've been
implementing stuff all day and reading
papers and it's been a
lot. But we did get the initial
implementation of impala v trace and
prioritize experience
replay. So this
is. I can't think of why this would
randomly fail on like why does this
thing work on breakout and not
snake? Like snake isn't any harder than
breakout. It could be, but completely
failing is
weird. It shouldn't like completely
fail.
do this. I don't think that does
anything
right. Try to read the paper and figure
out why more stuff don't
Well, I'm aware it's controlled in the
US, but I'm also I was pretty sure it's
not even easy to get a script for
that. I don't know.
I'm usually just on eight or nine hours
of sleep and a black cup of coffee is
more my
speed generally.
Just No, some of those are a lot easier
to get.
Yeah. I don't know. I still just
recommend getting enough sleep, getting
some exercise, and getting some coffee.
Whatever. Yeah. Yeah. I They're like all
people write all sorts of down threads
about this [ __ ] But it wasn't it like
for like for an arpsy or something,
right?
Okay. Well, this doesn't work. It works
on breakout. I don't know why it works
like almost the same as P as a J on
breakout and it doesn't work on it does
work on pawn and then it doesn't work on
any of the other so
far. Solve problem work back.
I you can try that but you're probably
not going to have a fun
time. I'm just tell you're probably not
going to have a fun
time. It's going to be like the Python
API stuff but like 10 times
worse. You will
try. Yeah.
New conversions for bindings are
good. All right. So, here's the
plan for folks
watching. My steps at
puffer.ai. We're solving reinforcement
learning. It's all going to be free and
open source and fast and simple.
If you want to follow all this and help
us out for free, just star the repo.
We're really close to 2K stars. There
not that many RL repos with 2K stars.
It'd be awesome to hit that soon. If you
want to get involved in depth,
discord.gg/puffer. Some of our best
contributors came in with zero RL
background. Hebat came in with zero
programming background and has done a
lot of good stuff lately.
And uh if
you want some more RL content, we've got
a blog here. There's a quick start guide
that I recommend, but then also there's
more content on X that you can't find
anywhere
else. So you can follow me there as
well. I usually work six, six and a half
days a week.
So tomorrow is going to be get some
exercise, get some RNR, do whatever
stuff I haven't had to do throughout the
week. I might be on for a little bit in
the afternoon, early evening. We'll see.
But if not, I will be back on
Monday. Likely working on all this stuff
more. Possibly switching over
to exploration algorithm side works.
Depends also on the results of this
guy. And uh also for contributors, I'm
having a technician over tomorrow. So
hopefully the cluster gets back online
appropriately and we're able to start
you know supporting more contributor
uh research with that once again. So
other than that, thanks folks and uh
yeah, enjoy your weekend and I will see
you tomorrow or on